let's talk about your new song wait no
more it feels like this is a perfect
song to release right now what inspired
the song for you initially it was just
kind of like this phrase that I would
sing you know as like a stand and it was
sort of like you know I'd be writing a
song and then I'm trying to find words
so I would sing wait no more it wasn't
this weird thing that I was like a
compulsion almost so I was in a session
with some really close friends and I
said you know why don't we just write
that so I can like almost throw it away
like I don't want yeah this is an
age-old like thing of you know you got
to smell the roses while they're there I
just kind of wanted to put my own spin
on that and write about that from my
personal perspective well the video was
so much fun it's a true that your
girlfriend had to step in as a
videographer during this time of
isolation yeah so she operated the
camera inside obviously couldn't bring
the director and the cinematographer
inside and it was really fun to make
something like with all those
limitations like I actually love the
limitations I think it makes like for a
much more interesting thing so I'm glad
we could do it and it worked out okay so
how did it feel then just kind of trash
in your living room it felt awesome felt
also like an expression of the song like
I think we also forget how temporary all
of the things are except for the people
we love and you know like I don't know
it's like whatever it's like a guitar
it's not really like the heart and soul
of music and it's like a flower vase or
whatever I don't know it was fun it felt
so good to just like trash my house I
also want to talk about the paint
there's that that was like a lot of
thick paint so I wanna know how long
that took that come off your body once I
got the paint all on myself we had to
wait like two hours to do the
haircutting Hart there was no way I was
getting out came out of my hair because
it was acrylic so it's basically like
dried plastic in your hair
it looks so sick that's why I wanted to
ask with painful like someone I think I
actually ripped a patch of my hair out
when I was trying to get it out so